we were totally shocked by your decision
Elsa we've really thought that you would
go back to arendelle with Anna after all
you are doing a great job as Queen but
honey Marin was right you really do
belong in the Enchanted Forest you'll be
closer to a to Holland where your powers
come from and you can get closer to all
the other spirits plus it's not like
you're that far from your family but
what does this mean for the future of
arendelle frozen to had a pretty
satisfying ending but fans are already
dreaming up plots for a third movie we
have to admit a lot of these fan
theories make total sense keep watching
for the best theories about frozen three
the ending of frozen - we can't believe
everything that happened in frozen -
there were a lot of storylines that had
to get wrapped up first honor realized
that the only way to freed the forest
was to destroy the dam the dam had been
built by her grandfather who used it to
trick the North aldrin it destroyed
their resources and her grandfather
attacked the tribes which angered the
spirits so they cut off the forest from
the rest of the world when Anna
destroyed the dam she also freed Elsa
who had been frozen in ad till Holland
this made Elsa's powers complete as the
fifth spirit she is the one who can
unite and calm the other spirits she
arrived just in time with a knock to
save arendelle from being destroyed by
the flood Elsa used her magic to bring
Olaf back to life water has memory and
snow is just frozen water Kristoff
finally proposed to Anna and also
realized that she belonged in the forest
with the other spirits causing onit to
become the queen of arendelle frozen to
was beyond epic and it's got fans
talking some are convinced that a third
and final installment is a shoo-in and
first and three theories are flying
around the internet as though they were
being guided by Gale herself Kristoff
can I borrow your wagon and Sven I'm not
very comfortable with the idea of that
Elsa's forest adventures the first
frozen three theory is all about Elsa
she's no longer the queen of arendelle
so what will she do with all of her time
one theory about Elsa is that she'll
finally get a love interest plenty of
fans notice some serious chemistry
between honey Marian and the ice queen
there are lots of fans who would love
see an Elsa love story also now that the
Enchanted Forest is open again it can be
totally safe some people in arendelle
still fear magic like Elsa's grandfather
or maybe news of the forest will travel
to the rest of the world someone else
will come and try to use the magic of
the forest also we'll have to stop them
she could also figure out more about her
parents she never did decode that
parchment she and Anna found in the
shipwreck the North aldrin said that her
mother was from one of the oldest
families in their culture but we don't
meet this family
Elsa might go try to find her distant
relatives Princess Anna is dead
Hans returns can we all agree that Hans
is pretty much the worst in the first
movie he's determined to take over
arendelle here's the thing about Hans
though he's the annoying little brother
of a huge family his chances of ever
ruling a kingdom are pretty slim
that's why he tried to woo on it and get
rid of Elsa he figured it was his best
shot at becoming king of anything
Hans might hear that on is now the queen
of arendelle he could think that it's
safe to come to try again because Elsa
isn't there
Hans might even convince his father or
some of his brothers to help him there
could be a whole army Anna would need
Elsa to come down from the forest to
help save arendelle again
Hans is also totally the type of person
to try and take over the enchanted
forest Hans would have gotten along
great with Ana's grandfather he could
end up fighting the North Waldron's and
then the forest might become cursed
again only Elsa and Anna can save the
forest are you totally obsessed with
Disney fan theories so are we be the
first to watch the hottest theories
about Disney movies when you subscribe
to the things want to be notified about
new videos make sure your mobile YouTube
settings are set to allow notifications
now let's get back to frozen three
theories keep watching to find out what
could happen with Kristoff and honest
children frozen a prequel we were
absolutely fascinated by the story of
Anna and Elsa's parents it would be so
cool to see more about them we know what
happened with arendelle attacking the
north all drones but what happened
before that we would love to see what
Queen I do know was like when she was
growing up and then there's
whole question of what happened after
where did I do not go after she saved
Agner we'd be really curious to know how
I do know made a life for herself as a
young girl all alone we also have to
wonder what else was going on in
arendelle people had to be pretty upset
about the forest being sealed off and
Eichner became king that very same day
but he was just a boy he had a lot to
learn and never had time to grieve
another possibility for a prequel could
happen way before I deunan Agner the
North aldrin czar in ancient people Elsa
was probably not the first person with
powers we think a movie about the
ancient north old ruins would be so cool
it could explain all about the magic of
the forest why is there only magic in
the forest we think there was probably a
time when magic was outside of the
forest to take a look at the trolls
they're made of stone just like the
earth Giants they are just a lot smaller
grandpappy has some magical abilities he
was able to heal Anna and erase her
memories as a kid he can see the future
a prequel could explain all about the
trolls and their magic how did they get
to arendelle there are so many questions
that still need to be answered and
prequels are a great way to do that
there could also be a prequel about what
happened when the forests sealed off it
was a magical place but something went
wrong
the North aldrin and though arendelle
soldiers were trapped for 34 years they
were constantly at odds with each other
we would love to see how the soldiers
learned how to survive the North aldrin
whole way of life had to change to can
you imagine not being able to really see
the sky for decades they were also used
to using the forest magic the spirits
help them with their day-to-day life but
after the forest was sealed from the
outside world
the spirits kind of disappeared that is
until Elsa woke them with her song it
would be cool to see what was happening
in the forest during those three decades
Anna and Kristoff Anna and Kristoff are
seriously couple goals these two are
just so in love there are way more
realistic than a lot of Disney couples
back up while I deal with this crook
here
did you call me
Christophe adores honor he helps her
instead of just trying to protect her
we're so glad he finally got over his
awkwardness and proposed at the end of
frozen to on is announced as the queen
of arendelle but it's not clear whether
or not she's married yet Kristoff gets
all dressed up along with Sven and Olaf
for Ana's special day so if they aren't
married yet frozen three could be about
the royal wedding but it can't just be
an easy wedding there would have to be
some major adventure perhaps Hans comes
back and kidnap Sanne
maybe Kristoff and Sven get lost while
they're out exploring and on and Olaf
have to find them
either way we really want to see a
wedding Kristoff attempting to write his
own vows would be so cute also would
have to come back to be maid of honor of
course we cast Fenn would be the best
man grand pabbie would perform the
ceremony you have to admit it would be
the best wedding ever a spin-off
everyone loves the main characters from
frozen Anna and Elsa are awesome
Kristoff and Sven are so much fun to
have around and Olaf is the cutest and
most hilarious snowman ever but there
are plenty of other characters that were
introduced these characters were so cool
we'd love a story about general Matthias
and his lost love in arendelle Ryder is
also a super cool character he was so
excited to see what life was like
outside of the forest maybe he and the
reindeer go on some grand adventure then
there's honey Marin we want to know so
much more about this character she is
really amazing but she's kind of
mysterious we think there could be a ton
of spin-offs based on the minor
characters from frozen to the next
generation you serious and it's the
latest model no I can't accept this you
have to no returns
now that Kristoff and honor are getting
married there will probably be a whole
new generation it would be cool to have
a movie all about on and Christoph's
children but what would it be about
well we think there's a good chance that
at least one of them will be magical
think about it Anna and Elsa are half
North old
Elsa was given her powers as a gift it
was because her mother saved her father
and got him out of the forest then the
forest sealed and her father tried to
make things right as the king but he
didn't really understand the past
ahna help the forest - she destroyed the
dam to save it
she broke the curse and freed the people
her children could be blessed with magic
powers - but Anna will know better than
to force her kids to conceal their
powers look what it did to Elsa in the
first movie see concede but Anna will
also know that she needs help we think a
movie about Ana's future daughter going
to the forest to live with her on Elsa
would be so awesome
I also would teach her niece how to use
her magic and since she's starting so
young she might become more powerful
than Elsa also can you imagine how cute
Anna and Kristoff children would be
they'd grow up with Olaf and Sven to
play with it would be cool and adorable
we really hope that one day we get a
movie all about the next frozen
generation that's a rat which of these
theories do you like best for frozen
three do you have your own theories
about a future movie let us know in the
comments section Elsa's powers were too
much for this world
now we must pray they are enough
[Music]
alsa you've gone on such a journey back
in the days with the first frozen film
you were scared of your powers you
wanted to hide yourself away but by the
end of frozen - you totally own your
magic gift and now you know who you
really are with all of this newfound
self-confidence you're more powerful
than ever you've even met up with four
other awesome spirit powers and found
your place in the world we couldn't be
happier for you Alice has been searching
for the truth about her ice powers all
her life and she finally gets the
answers in frozen - which makes her
extra powerful keep watching to the end
to discover what new alliances will
increase Elsa's power even more Anna no
I have my powers to protect me Elsa's
power is finally explained first things
first we can all agree that knowledge is
power and in frozen - Elsa finally gets
the answers to all her questions about
her ice powers she spends nearly the
entire movie and the first film trying
to figure out where her magic comes from
we learned that even her parents weren't
sure about the origins of their
daughter's abilities their ship got
wrecked on their journey to OTO Holland
in their search for the truth and the
answer that Elsa eventually discovered
was that her powers were a gift not a
curse the nature spirits rewarded I
dunno for her selfless act of saving
Agner by giving her a magical daughter
simply by knowing the reason for her
power Elsa's power is increased Elsa
finds a community in the original frozen
film Elsa is an outcast she banishes
herself from her kingdom and chooses to
live in isolation on the North Mountain
we get the perfect insight into her
frame of mind when she sings let it go
they say that no person is an island and
you really can't get through life
entirely on your own so Elsa needs to
find a community that she can thrive in
and express her powers to their fullest
even though Elsa reunites with Anna at
the end of the first movie we see that
she's still not settled at the beginning
of frozen - it's clear that Elsa isn't
totally comfortable in the family setup
and the others still don't totally
understand her when Anna asks Kristoff
as Elsa seemed weird to you
she seems like Elsa it's clear that Elsa
isn't amongst others on the same
wavelength that's her she can't get
fully involved in Ana's game of charades
sure she's distracted by the voice
that's calling her but this kind of
endorsee constrained entertainment just
isn't her cup of tea also explains the
disconnect she's feeling when she sings
into the unknown she wonders if the
voice calling her is someone who's a
little bit like her who knows deep down
she's not where she's meant to be and
eventually she admits that she's longed
to go into the unknown
she needs to be free add amongst nature
and by the end of frozen to she's found
the perfect environment by living in the
enchanted forest amongst the other four
spirits she can finally unleash her
powers to the max Elsa connects with
Anna Elsa and Anna have always had a
tricky relationship ever since Elsa
accidentally froze her little sister's
head when they were kids they've managed
to mend their relationship at various
points along the way but Alice's still
wasn't entirely on the same page as Anna
in frozen - Elsa promises Anna we do
this together okay I'm famous but she
ends up betraying that promise when she
sends Anna and Olaf off in a frozen
canoe no matter how close they were
getting Elsa's still felt a disconnect
from her sister she still felt like she
couldn't fully embrace her powers and go
as far as she needed to while Anna was
around however by the end of the movie
Elsa has finally found a way to connect
with Anna without stifling her powers by
being the protector of the enchanted
forest Elsa can live in her element
while still having contact with her
sister she can connect with Anna through
letters and meetups
but without having to hold in her powers
also frees herself from imposed duty
it's important that Elsa renounces her
role as queen of arendelle this is a
position that was thrust upon her when
her parents passed away it wasn't the
roles that she chose for herself by
being pushed into a station of imposed
duty Elsa was limited she couldn't use
her ice powers for much more than
sparkly celebration fireworks
she couldn't unleash the full force of
her powers while she was queen of
arendelle but by passing that mantle on
to Anna who perfectly suits the role
Elsa could free herself from that
restraining responsibilities sure she
ends up in another position of power as
the protector of the Enchanted Forest
but the important difference is that she
chose that role
for herself and it's a job that lets her
use her full range of powers without
restriction Elsa knows who she is in the
first frozen movie it's clear that Elsa
suffers from self doubts she had such a
traumatizing childhood conceal it it's
no wonder she ended up feeling like a
burden she didn't understand her true
nature by finally getting those answers
in frozen - Elsa could discover her true
self she can now embrace her powers and
everything that makes her who she is
she literally lets her hair down in
frozen - when she gets to Otto Holland
and she embraces her true self before we
reveal what new allies make Elsa even
more powerful to invite you to be the
first to watch our latest frozen videos
so if you haven't already subscribed to
the things and tap that notification
bell if you're watching on your phone go
to your YouTube settings and turn on
your notifications now back to Elsa Elsa
finds her purpose Elsa's big musical
moment on Oda Holland is a major turning
point show yourself
is like an anthem of self-acceptance
self realization and self love she sings
about a friend she's always known and
how she feels like she is home
Elsa goes on to sing about feeling so
certain that she's there for a reason
the reason she was born she's finally
finding the answer she's waited for all
her life the voice that's been calling
her is her mother who sings come my
darling homeward bound and also replies
I am found some fans have wondered
whether the voice actually belongs to
Elsa and if it is in fact Elsa herself
that has been calling out for the Ice
Queen to find her purpose either way
watching Elsa finally embrace her true
calling is such an emotional moment Elsa
can push herself to the limit not only
does Elsa push herself to get to adda
Holland and discovered the truth about
the past she also goes deeper than she's
been advised to go pappi had warned Elsa
and Anna about their journey before they
set out to the enchanted forest Pappy
told Anna magic is very alluring without
you she might lose herself to it and
going back to their mother's lullaby
about auda Holland I do know has also
warned Elsa about going too far I do
know sings about the river dive down
deep into her sound but not too far or
you'll be drowned Elsa stands on the
precipice knowing that if she leaps down
deep into
memories of the past they will destroy
her but she does it anyway sacrificing
herself to find the truth and as she
begins to freeze she shoots out the
answer to Anna to make sure their
grandfather's betrayal is known Elsa has
pushed herself to the ultimate limit and
it takes such a huge strength to do that
with such strength comes power Elsa has
tamed her powers we're so relieved when
Elsa unfreezes and comes back bringing
back Olaf - there's some debate amongst
fan as to whether Elsa actually passes
when she freezes and comes back as a
spirit or if she simply came back to
life she certainly looks more ethereal
after her frozen moment she's paler and
more ghostly buzz like Bruni she's a
physical being capable of being hugged
by Anna so either way whether she came
back to life or is a spirit Elsa exists
in some forms and in this new form she's
totally in control of her powers she
manages to beat the water surge when the
dam comes down and reaches arendelle in
time to save the kingdom from the
massive wave her ice powers quell in the
water and all is calm and the important
point to make is that also is able to do
that because the spirits agreed she is
working together and finding harmony
with the other powers now - the fact
that she's tamed her powers stands in
stark contrast of the first movie by the
end of the original frozen film we see
that Elsa isn't much more in control of
her powers but she still isn't totally
there yet after all she accidentally
freezes her hands to the balcony at the
beginning of the second film but by the
end of the sequel she's owning it Elsa
can tame other powers not only does Elsa
manage to take charge of her own powers
but she also manages to control the
other spirits powers - and she does have
to use force in the end sure she
unleashes her ice powers in a battle
with the fire spirit to begin with but
then she realizes that it's actually a
cute little salamander called Bruni and
she finds that she can tame Bruni by
being kind to him and by using her own
powers to make him happy by giving him
snow piles to jump in or snowflakes to
eat she also gets playful with Gale the
wind spirit and as for NOK the water
spirit in horse form Elsa totally takes
charge she manages to rain and knock
quite literally to ride the water spirit
across the waves to Otto Holland and she
finds a way to work together
with a horse and harmony disability to
not only tame her own powers but the
other Spears powers to makes Elsa even
more powerful Elsa has four new powers
to play with as Elsa is working in
harmony with the four spirits she now
has four new powers to play with this
has practical benefits for example Elsa
is so friendly with Gale that she can
send letters to Anna thanks to the
helpful wind spirit and when earth fire
wind water and ice all connects they
make an unbeatable force else is at the
center of that power and we couldn't be
happier for her what did you think about
else's journey in the sequel do you
believe she's happier now living in the
enchanted forest or do you wish she was
still living with Anna sound off in the
comments
Oh distracted worried hey Elsa we know
that you have a lot going on in frozen
to an unknown voice is calling your name
and it wants you to go north you're
going to travel into the great unknown
to discover more about yourself and save
arendelle if anyone can save arendelle
but what comes next some fans still
think you need a love interest or will
you decide that being queen isn't for
you we think there are definitely enough
storylines for a third movie and I know
what that means
frozen fans are already excited about
the prospect of a frozen three movie
Disney is far from confirming the third
film but that doesn't mean it's off the
table stay tuned as we reveal why frozen
3 needs to happen love stories one of
the biggest reasons fans want frozen 3 -
- has everything to do with love stories
we love seeing Anna and Kristoff slowly
fall for each other in the first film
like it they are just perfect for each
other in frozen - they are still
together
we know that Kristoff wants to propose
to Anna but he keeps trying to find the
right time from what we've heard about
the new movie he keeps getting
interrupted when he tries to propose
nice poor Kristoff frozen three would be
a great opportunity to explore their
romance imagine if something happens
bother planning their wedding
maybe Hans comes back into the picture
after all he was technically engaged to
Anna will you marry me yes that could be
some serious drama or maybe something
happens to Kristoff before the wedding
and Anna and Elsa have to save him there
is definitely no shortage of storylines
for a movie all about Kristoff and Anna
getting married there are also plenty of
fans who think Elsa needs a love
interest
you probably remember the give Elsa a
girlfriend campaign it started before
frozen 2 was even announced many fans
were disappointed to learn that Elsa
will not be falling in love in the
second movie find who is calling to you
but there is always the possibility of a
3 cold in fact a new site called we got
this covered
reported that Elsa is getting a
girlfriend in frozen 3 but we aren't
sure who their super secret source is
Disney execs have said that there are
currently no plans for a third movie
they will have to wait and see how
successful frozen 2 is backless ad and
at this point they don't even have a
plot for the third installment we
guessed people who want an Elsa love
story will have to keep hoping Elsa
stays behind Elsa's never really felt
like she fit in because of her magic and
her powers just keep getting stronger in
frozen - she says there's boys and from
what the trailers say it seems that
she'll get all her answers about her
magic in the enchanted forest
no one has been allowed in or out of the
forest for decades but her magic allows
her n what if Elsa finally finds where
she belongs
we could totally see her choosing to
stay behind at the end of frozen - she
never wanted to become Queen at her
young age do you have to go you'll be
fine Elsa but she lost her parents she
might not want to be the queen of
arendelle if she stays in a place of
magic she might tell Anna to take over
the throne and that would definitely
open up a possibility for a third movie
Anna doesn't want to rule either and she
wants to stay with her sister we do this
together ok
I promise frozen three could be about
Elsa needing to return to arendelle to
save her sister from some threats or
maybe she only wanted to stay away to
find herself and get better at magic a
third movie could be about her journey
home all about Anna the frozen movies
maybe about sisterly love but they're
more geared towards else's journey the
first movie was about Elsa learning to
accept her powers and Anna trying to
convince her to come home You Belong
down in arendelle
so do you the second movie is about Elsa
learning more about her powers and
saving arendelle Anna is there because
she supports her sister plenty of fans
think frozen 3 should be mostly about
Anna there have been lots of theories
that Anna might have powers of her own
she might be the fire queen to Elsa's
ice queen frozen 3 could definitely
explore ah no learning to harness her
own magic but maybe on a doesn't have
powers she could go on her own adventure
perhaps she tries to find out what
happened to their parents or maybe Hans
comes back and causes all sorts of
problems for her it could be that Elsa
needs to save Anna this time around and
we would love to see Kristoff be a huge
hero either way a movie about Anna would
be totally awesome we will have to wait
and see how frozen 2 ends but we know
there is still so much does Nika do with
Elsa and Anna frozen 3 would make so
many fans happy why do you think there
should be a third frozen movie don't be
shy tell us your theories in the
comments thanks for tuning in
be sure to like this video and subscribe
to the things for more great content
we'll catch you next time
you